okay so invincible episode 7 has a lot
of pieces falling into place
and the entry includes several easter
eggs hidden details and things you
missed
it pulls from a lot of different issues
throughout the run and beautifully
brings together the overarching story
these different plot points include the
end of issue 9 which saw the
resurrection of the immortal
issue 10 which had nolan fighting a
giant kaiju before he was attacked by
the character
issue 0 which really came up to 22 had
mark tell amber of his true identity
there's also the secret origins of the
immortal which appears
and issue 34 and 5 in which we see robot
or rather rudy getting put into a new
body
now if you've just heard me list off
those numbers like some big geek at a
comic store
and you've probably noticed that they
happened years apart in the original
series
this episode combines a lot of big story
moments but it also adds some amazing
new changes in it that take this story
in a really interesting direction
we open with debbie waking up to find
her husband gone and unlike the books
she's now well aware of the monster
she's married
in the original work she didn't discover
his darker side until much later on when
it was revealed to the world
like cecil she is starting to truly
suspect how evil he is at this point
but similar to him they're both keeping
it hush they both know nolan
is the most dangerous man on earth and
therefore have to be cautious in order
to not arouse suspicion
cut to mark and co who are traveling
home from upstate university
i can't believe that last week i missed
that d.a sinclair was voiced by ezra
miller
in addition to this justin roiland who
voices rick and rick and morty
also voiced doug cheston which i should
have recognized
just by the burp now we catch adam eve
exhausted in her treehouse
and see her drinking from a coffee mug
with tt written on it
this stands for teen team the group that
she was originally a member of
in issue 22 of the comics the character
flew to africa to help out there
but in the series she's remained in
america however the treehouse itself is
still based on an
african design giving a little nod to
the comics
in issue 32 she and mark sat on the roof
of her home there
and though the character doesn't join
her at this point it does sort of happen
towards the end of the episode
when the pair have a conversation at a
waterfall at the graysons
debbie lists off the theories that i'm
sure many fans have had over the last
couple of weeks
especially the ones who don't know the
twist she believes that nolan could have
been brainwashed
or that the family might be being held
to ransom and it's nice that the show's
second guess to what the viewers would
think
nolan's ego here is definitely his
downfall and
after i was curious as to why he just
didn't toss the costume into the sun
or hide it somewhere on the planet he
says part of him wanted to have it
discovered
nolan is bearing a great big secret that
we'll discuss in the more spoiler-heavy
part of the video at the end
but he's clearly living on borrowed time
debbie tells him to get out which is
completely different to the original
work
as in that the pair were happily married
until mark discovered the truth
nolan leaves by flying through the roof
and this sign of aggression
is clearly used to intimidate her after
punching several holes in the house
he's finally left it one showing that he
would rather destroy the home he's built
than have the truth come out juxtaposing
this mark does the opposite with amber
and realizing that they will likely
break up if he doesn't come clean
he reveals that he's invincible now the
conversation goes in the complete
opposite direction to how it did in
issue zero
leading up to that amber had suspected
that mark was a drug dealer or something
and she was very much over the moon to
learn that he was a superhero
here though amber reveals that she
already knew about it and that she's
furious over the fact that he's lied to
her for so long
mark like nolan two leaves showing that
they can't do right for doing wrong
women hey i'm just kidding ladies you
know i love you now i've just realized
that i've not revealed
myself yet and if this is your first
time here then welcome to the heavy
spoilers show
i'm your host paul and we do videos like
this each and every day
so if you love invincible then you need
to stay locked to the channel
please click the thumbs up button if
you've been enjoying the breakdown so
far
and don't forget to subscribe so that
you don't miss our coverage on the
finale
anyway back at the guardians hq monster
girl has recovered from her surgery
and she gets a warm welcome from the
rest of the team rexplode has put her
face on milk cartons
and even gone so far is to replace the
stuff inside with beer
monster girl seems quite taken by him
and this speaks to why a robot decides
to clone his body
we also learn that black samson has had
his powers return
which will be interesting to see later
on in the series
elsewhere the maulers are confronted by
robot who
seemingly has started to malfunction the
character's true body has been
transported across to them
and we finally get to confirm that he is
actually the person in the tank
robot or rather rudolph connors has a
link up drilled into his head
and through this he's able to control
the orange drones that we've seen
throughout the series
after hearing of monster girl's plea to
be normal this inspired him to take his
own measures to free himself of his body
and this is why he enlisted the help of
the maulers i don't know if i'm reaching
here but i do get a lot of stephen
hawking vibes from the character
as he was a genius scientist that
unfortunately due to a disability
was confined to live a certain way now
rudolph is of course a comic book
character
so he can do things that hawking's
couldn't but even the robotic voice i
think is meant to mimic the real life
figure
now an interesting deviation happens
when we learn that robot is wanting to
pay the maulers with a control collar
that makes whoever wears its subservient
originally in the comics he just offered
them all the money that they wanted
and then revealed after the cloning that
he didn't actually have it and was just
lying
the bargain works though and they agreed
to switch minds
and speaking of minds mark is losing his
as he talks to william very very tenuous
link there but will learns that mark's
father is omniman
and tries to talk him into sucking it up
will also talks about him being like
someone who's been ripped in half
which foreshadows the immortal having
that done to him later
yes it's a reach now debbie is taken
directly to cecil
who reveals that he's known for a while
that nolan killed the guardians
he's been studying mark's blood not only
to find weaknesses for omniman but also
to have something in store in case he
turns bad too
he knows that mark is the only person on
earth capable of stopping his father
and it's so tense watching cecil's
entire plan play out
we see nolan atop of mount everest
planning out how he's going to tell mark
and the pair actually went to this
location earlier in the season
i suspect that it will be somewhere that
shows up in the finale next week
and definitely bear this in mind as we
head towards that episode
in a big body horror scene rudy is taken
out of his canister
and he says the air is toxic to him
which is also his weakness in the comics
similar to the source material the mall
has explained that his mind isn't being
transferred
it's being copied and he won't suddenly
wake up in the next body
now there are complications which aren't
present in the comics and the mullers
have to compensate during the
duplication process due to rudolph's
brain being slightly different to a
normal human
whether this means his intelligence will
be limited going forward
we don't know but clearly there will be
some differences
the awakening feels like it was ripped
straight out of issue 34
and rex rudy ends up destroying his
original self in a moment that
even the maulers were wiping away a tear
over i was really really excited now
really
actually hands over the key to the
caller which is something he didn't do
originally
however he does launch a big drone much
like in the comics in order to take them
down
now the mothers to my surprise don't get
arrested
in the original work they were sent back
to prison but here
rudy is called away and thus they're
able to operate freely
they've actually switched the order of
things and in the original work they
escaped the supermax
and then went and resurrected the
immortal it was much later that they
were called in to help rudy
and when the work was done they were
captured once more i love the changeups
like this
and it allows for them to constantly
shift your expectations throughout
even if you know the source material
just as well as i do which
i bloody love it now nolan arrives home
to discover cecil's forces
and he goes full homeland on them it's
just so gory watching him pushing
people's bodies in half and twisting
their torsos
and at this point i was like this is
just what we want to see
it's such a good scene that shows how
dangerous he is when he's off the leash
and nolan takes absolutely no prisoners
omniman murders donald and this never
happened in the comics
though the character was badly injured
in issue 16.
now i am aware of spoiling the show for
people who haven't read the comics
and though in the original run donald is
in it for the majority
i actually believe that they have fully
killed the character off at this point
and that he won't be showing up in the
future
he detonates a bomb which destroys the
hideout home
and to cecil's dismay it barely hurts
omniman at all
nolan goes and intimidates william and
the guy is in full supervillain mode at
this point
desperate to find mark so he can get to
him before cecil does
at the guardian's hq rudy arrives and
introduces himself
we know he's a 30 year old but he's
actually chosen this teenage appearance
because he wants to get closer to
monster girl and appear on her level
in issue 35 he was introduced by cecil
but here he shows up alone and rex is
outraged over being cloned
monster girl figures out that she did it
for him whereas in the work he denies
doing it to try and appeal to her
elsewhere mark meets eve and from a
satellite
cecil spies on them in nolan he launches
a weapon known as the hammer
which didn't appear in the original work
and i actually think this might be a nod
to the immortal hulk
now all comics take from other comics
and i don't think that this is a ripoff
or anything before you start yeah
in that though iron man was trying to
take down the hulk and he fired a weapon
known as helios which was a satellite
built to harness pure sunlight
it too was a countermeasure put in place
to destroy a superpowered being
and it also decimated the landscape with
a harsh blue light
whereas it almost killed the hulk
omniman just gets a nosebleed and thus
cecil resorts to other plants he goes to
face him in the desert
and using his teleportation powers he
manages to taunt him
the pair never had a standoff in the
comics at this point and cecil admitted
after the first part of omniman's arc
that he never suspected a thing he also
calls in the anime and
last week's episode saw d.a sinclair
being taken in by cecil
and issue 37 actually ended with him
recruiting the character
we learned that cecil's robo copped dead
soldiers so that they can serve their
country once more
and it just shows a lens that he's
willing to go to to take the character
down whatever he throws at nolan though
he completely decimates
and thus he calls in a giant kaiju
elsewhere the maul is resurrect the
immortal
and we actually see flashes of his life
as he's being revived
these pull heavily from his origins
issue and in that we learn that he had a
backstory very similar to vandal
savage's
in the comics savage existed for
millennia and he was made immortal after
he came into contact with the meteor
the immortal two was an ancient warrior
that touched a mysterious energy force
and this stabilized his cells so that he
could live forever
over the years he was a knight and even
abraham lincoln before he became a
superhero
even mark flynn to join the battle and
similar to the ending of issue 9 the
immortal awakens and flies off to avenge
his death
now it does turn out that robot gave
them all his bad schematics
and it's likely that he knew that they
would resurrect the immortal because of
the frankenstein motif that runs
throughout
the fight scene between the immortal and
omni man plays out much in the same way
that it did in issue 10
with nolan putting his hand through his
body before ripping him apart
at this point i was completely blown
away by the episode
and by far it's my favorite in the
series there's so much going on and once
the action picks up
it's completely non-stop now because the
series was written before the internet
and cell phones became a part of normal
life
the world wasn't able to watch the fight
live however
here omniman's battle is broadcast
across the planet
and this also means there's no going
back when it comes to keeping his plan
under wraps
he will have to reveal it next week and
we all can finally talk openly about it
now what i love about this ending is
that omniman kills the immortal
whereas mark restrains the kaiju showing
how much they differ
nolan obviously didn't want to do it
like this but he's been left with no
other option
as we head into the finale a full
spoiler is ahead for what happens in the
comics and if you don't want things
ruined then i recommend that you turn
off now
are you still here good well turns out
that veltrum isn't the kind and loving
civilization that we've come to believe
it is
after they rooted out all the weak ones
in their society they decided to enact a
new order upon the world
and thus send out their conquerors
across the universe
known as the world betterment committee
nolan was one of its greatest soldiers
and over the centuries he took over many
planets you see vultromites
actually age slower the older they get
and he's thousands and thousands of
years old
when voltron's forces became stretched
too thin because they'd conquered so
much
they decided to try a new plan of attack
a trojan horse if you will
they would send out their soldiers to
planets who would pretend to be their
saviors
all the while weakening their defenses
this is why he killed the guardians
as they might have been able to stop the
invasion of the veltromites
and over the years nolan beat other
entities that were trying to invade
earth
so that the planet was safe for his
army's arrival this will likely be
revealed next week
but i'd of course love to see them
change it up a bit so who knows what
could happen
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
also i just want to give a huge thank
you to our editor christian
over at beyond epic for saving the
channel this week i've had a lot of
personal issues going on at home and
he's stepped in to edit pretty much
every single video and it's really
helped me out
please give the guy a thumbs up and
thank you for all the support
now if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the finale of falcon in the
winter soldier which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire last episode
from top to bottom to discuss
everything you need to know about it so
it's definitely worth watching
right after this without the way thank
you for sticking through the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace